yeah exactly five months today I've been
loving it very much here and one of the
reasons to come from Cornell to Stanford
is is in part because of Silicon Valley
and all of these various you know
companies that are barely represented on
the screen the reason I just put them
barely on the screen is because there
are kind of the backdrop to what I'm
going to talk about today and this
research really I'll be very upfront
with you it it comes from a feeling a
belief that a lot of the prevailing
wisdom around how social media or
communication technology affect our
well-being okay so I'll go over a little
bit of the prevailing wisdom and that is
that most the time when you use
technology you're you're you're damaging
your well-being your relationships
well-being etc and if we were to talk to
my mom or some of your moms or dads
there there's a very strong response
that yeah like all these kids texting
all the time and all the distractions
are taking place and text messaging
isn't a real interaction and it's not
just in the the sort of real world the
popular press but also a lot of academic
studies so there's a lot of work that
really comes across my you know with my
gmail alerts on a daily basis that these
kind of technologies are really damaging
or negative people are doing using
Facebook because they're narcissistic or
it's destroying relationships because
they're not really sharing real emotions
I know that once everything becomes
text-based we can no longer share
emotions with each other and so the work
I'm gonna talk about today really is to
examine that prevailing wisdom closely
the sort of advanced preview of the
conclusion is that I think just because
we're using technology the 50 60 years
of discoveries if you had in social
science about how humans behave think
believe and love don't go out the window
and that's why I include affordances
here I'm not going to go into a lot of
depth about what exactly an affordance
is but rather that using technology
allows us to do and
accomplish and try different things and
so a lot of these approaches I think are
a little over simplistic but if we think
about the various affordances that is
things we can do with tech we're gonna
see some unique properties so that this
idea that once we've gone from
face-to-face nonverbal interaction to
text that everything goes to hell right
I just don't think that's gonna be right
all right so here's the three kinds of
psychological things I'm going to talk
about today the first is a notion of
self affirmation which is really
important psychological topic we'll go
into some emotional dynamic stuff and
I'm going to finish with one of my
favorite studies that I've been involved
in the last five years or so which is
how texting during surgery can change
how much narcotics you need okay so
first off let's let's just start with
this idea of using facebook major sort
of meme I think in the popular media and
the popular sort of psychology is that
one of the main things for using
Facebook is is a narcissistic function
the narcissism increasing and the reason
we do it is we just like to look at
ourselves and how awesome we are okay
very possible but another possibility is
that we could be using Facebook because
it actually does gives provides a
psychological value and what might that
value be well it could be self affirming
so self affirmation is a very well
studied concept Claude Steele who's now
here at Stanford first sort of came up
with this concept has been tested
hundreds if not a thousand times
basically idea here is that when you're
reminded of things that are important to
you that you are stronger
psychologically in a whole host of ways
they've shown that you know being a self
affirmed can overcome stereotype threat
for people doing math tests it can help
you overcome smoking I mean it's a it's
an amazing phenomena and it really it
basically works like this whenever you
face some kind of a threat to yourself
like oh I don't want to smoke this but
I'm not good enough I'm gonna probably
smoke this cigarette it leads to these
defensive mechanisms that then cause you
to perform sub-optimally on whatever
task
you're gonna do and that's this
defensive miss problem all these
defensive miss things kick in because
you're worried about your your threat to
your identity and who you are it's a
very psychological thing and it turns
out if you get people to do self
affirmation here that is remind
themselves about what's important to
them in their lives their family their
job their purpose in life you all can
imagine if your just think for a second
what's really important to you if you
were to think about that then that would
lead to self affirmation and what it
does is it reduces this this
defensiveness
that automatically engages when you're
starting to feel threatened okay so all
of you have had been in situations where
you feel anxious you have a big deadline
like say SIGGRAPH but those people
probably aren't here and you're writing
you're like oh my god I'm not gonna get
it done and unless you overcome some of
these defensive things than
procrastination kicks in so this is a
very typical kind of psychological
dynamic let me show you how
psychologists do this test whether the
self affirmation thing works there's two
conditions people are random aside to
come in in the first condition they're
asked to write about their most
important values you can see here this
person I'm always covered by my
relationships and grateful I have such
wonderful people in my life across
cultures that's the number-one value
people tend to report is family friends
people relationships okay so they would
do that or they're assigned to the
control condition they just be asked to
like list some stuff so in this case
they're asked to list their least
important values so this person's like
well a government politics it's my least
valued choice I know others you know
value it but I don't okay so what we
want to do is think is there a way in
which we could look at whether Facebook
performs a self affirming task or not
the way we did that is we sort of
created an analogue to this treatment
control approach one person comes into
our lab and they would be asked to look
at their own profile they're being told
that this is like an HCI task and
they're just to review their profile
we're gonna ask them questions about it
later to see like whether it works for
them etc and so this is Kate's profile
and she would just look at that now the
next person that came in
would then be yoked to Kate's profile
okay
so now their task is we want you to just
look at a profile we're gonna ask you
questions later HCI design type frame
and we're gonna get you to look at this
profile and just take a look at it study
it
lastly questions later so what's
happened here is Kate is looking at her
own page which we're gonna predict has
information about things that are
important to her her family her friends
things that she values like group she's
in etc over here the next participant
we'll call him Dave Dave comes in he
listed exactly the same stimuli that
Kate looked at exactly the same but
these are not important to Dave
they're like people he doesn't know
their groups he's not familiar with or
lists certainly doesn't identify with
and so in a way you can see the design
is that we have important values
reflected an essay reflected we think on
Facebook and unimportant values in an
essay reflected in someone else's
profile everybody good with the design
so far yeah means that you get exactly
what somebody else got right so not
everybody looked at Kate's profile Kate
would come in Dave is next so he would
look at that and then Michael comes in
and Lydia looks at Michael's right so
you were yoked to some other person in
the experiment well you would look at
Michaels
David look at Kate's Sam would look at
gingers I'm running out of names does
that make sense so basically there's
like I think we had about an f40 so
there's 40 people that looked at their
own and there's 40 people that looked at
one of the other persons good question
any other questions okay let's check in
see first of all whether we get self
affirmation how do they measure this in
psychology well you can oh yeah so let
me tell you actually the the way we
threaten them and everything so they
come in the lab and they
they have to give a speech I was in a
communication department at Cornell and
so giving a speech is not unheard of and
they give a speech and then they say
well we're gonna analyze that you're
gonna get some feedback go look at your
profile go look at this other person's
profile and wait for the feedback and
then everybody got really negative
feedback so your speech sucked and with
various reasons etc and in the classic
way and psychology later do this is then
they ask you basic questions about the
feedback you received how good was the
feedback how useful what do you think
about the person that gave the feedback
etc and you can combine those questions
into essentially a defensive 'no
smeshariki back where they how able were
they to take it in think about it and
say okay yeah I can use that and discard
the things that I don't like versus ah
sucked it was terrible feedback and
that's defensiveness kicking in right
okay so here's how you measure it you
can see in the classic condition here
the people that were affirmed right so
they wrote about the values that they
cared about they were more accepting of
this negative feedback than the people
in the no value or low value condition
okay over here people that looked at
their own profile they were more
accepting of the feedback than people
that looked at somebody else's profile
and if you look at that from a
statistical point of view those
differences between here and here and
here and here are identical there is no
difference between those differences
suggesting that Facebook is is self
affirming very much in the way that the
classic treatment does okay and in fact
if you look even further we can ask well
what were the changes that we're taking
place here you can see people that
looked at their own profile versus
somebody else's and they feel much more
connected much more loved supported
giving etc and these are things that
also occur in classic self affirmation
okay all right so that's good that made
us feel pretty good that maybe we're not
just narcissus going to look at
ourselves on Facebook but actually we're
going to Facebook because it has some
sort of psychological value but you
might be thinking as I did like well
it's really cool
it's a weird and kind of abstract thing
like this accepting of feedback so in a
follow-up study this is part of Catalina
Toma one of my former students
dissertation she did another study in
which people came in and they did the
same speech thing and they were
basically given positive feedback after
their speech or really negative feedback
after their speech okay and then they
were told you finished it really quickly
so if you'd like you can do another
study and you can double your points you
can get more points participation points
and we have a list of five other studies
we're doing a lab you can choose which
one you'd like to do okay so in the new
12 so it wasn't super positive it was
like neutral but but fairly positive
neutral we can basically just measure
how many of those people after they got
neutral feedback after doing the speech
wanted to do each of these things so we
said there's a Facebook study there's a
study on online news the studying on
videogames study on YouTube and a study
on online music which of those would you
like to go into and effectively it was
random people were choosing those
randomly based on their interests so it
didn't look very systematic Facebook
people chose to go to the Facebook 30%
30% of all the people in this study had
a neutral feedback went to Facebook now
the question is what about the people
that got really negative feedback from
their speech okay if it's self affirming
like we think from the first study what
should happen right way more should go
to Facebook and fewer go to those other
ones
but if Facebook is really the what we
were getting is maybe like engagement or
exciting or enjoying procrastinating
whatever then we should still see no
difference because the feedback had
nothing to do with Facebook it was to do
with this speech okay and here's what we
find it basically doubles the number of
people that want to go look at Facebook
after they get terrible feedback is they
want to go to Facebook okay and this is
exactly what psychology psychologists
would predict that after a negative
event in your life you seek out self
affirmation okay and that's what they
were doing here we are
and this suggests at the very least that
okay maybe narcissism plays some role in
it in in the you know huge amount of
time people spend on Facebook but it's
certainly the case that it's not just
narcissism right you could go there
because it can be psychologically
valuable for you all right what about
emotion well emotional dynamics I think
are really interesting in my field
there's a very strong assumption and
starting from about 1986 or so that once
people are going into text away from
face-to-face they can't share emotions
very well any emotions that do get
shared are gonna be negative so this was
to explain explain some of the early
flaming kind of things that you know
verbs we're seen in early news groups
that is that once you don't have the
nonverbal in the face you can't
communicate emotion and you've all heard
terms like communications like 70%
nonverbal or 80 or 90 make up your
number you know cuz that's what it is
it's totally made up
it's a mischaracterization of a 1967
Mehrabian study and it's insane I hear I
honestly hear on a probably a monthly
basis in communication that
communication is an percent nonverbal
it's just a made-up thing so what
happens though when we go into motion is
is Lou is it not possible to feel
emotion from text I'm going to show you
a study that I think empirically shows
that emotion reflects text but I also
would just say like read Shakespeare
right think about an email that pissed
you off like of course emotion you'd
come through text but here's one of my
favorite studies not by us but it was by
Golder and Macy some colleagues at
Cornell and what we're looking at here
is one of the first sort of big social
science Twitter studies 550 million
tweets from around the world
time-stamped and on the top what we're
seeing each line is a day and PA stands
for positive effect that's the percent
of words in the tweets that contained
percent of words that contain positive
effect okay and down here is negative
effect and this is midnight
well actually it's 12:01 and this is
11:59 okay so you're starting very
early in the morning noon and midnight
yeah so we're looking at a days rhythm
and what do you see you see that
positive effect crashes during the wee
hours of the morning picks up during
coffee time you see that the afternoon
is no good and then people get happy
around
well happy hour right now negative
effect you see peaks around 3:00 in the
morning if you're up at 3:00 in the
morning
either having one of those like awesome
you're never gonna forget nights or
you're like insomniac you're working
late and it's not cool and then negative
effect actually decreases there's a
little bit of a pickup during weekdays
after lunch well-known called the post
lunch dip and then you see actually also
increases which is an important point
positive effect and negative effect are
not the ends of a continuum you can have
high negative and positive effect so
they're somewhat they're independent all
right does anybody know what biological
process this is recognize that circadian
rythms this is a circadian rhythm it's a
very well studied physiological dynamic
and here we're seeing it in the language
of tweets okay so does a single tweet
reflect exactly my emotion no at scale
does it reflect emotion felt emotion I'm
going to argue that this study says yes
okay messy lots of air but we're seeing
that we're seeing the circadian rhythm
okay so I got interested in can people
detect it emotion in text and it did a
bunch of studies I'd get people to
pretend to be happy or sad and then text
with somebody and see if the other
person could tell they could we'd make
people happier sad see if the other
person could tell they could but really
the like
the objective here is something called
emotional contagion because then it's
not about like assessing another
person's mood it's about that moods can
be contagious so the theory of emotional
contagion argues that when other people
are feeling emotion it Prime's emotions
in you this happens automatically and
mechanistically so we're actually not
necessarily thinking about it or not
saying oh Michael sad there for Iams
and all the work up to ours had
suggested that they don't know what the
mechanism is but presumably it's
nonverbal so it's its motion its facial
some speculation that there's like a
scent that's related to motion that we
haven't detected yet but other but
humans can pick up on that so we want to
know could you see emotional contagion
where there's no nonverbal people don't
see each other they don't even know each
other but they're communicating by a bit
via text so I'm going to show you one of
a series of the studies that we did and
but it'll give you an idea of how we go
off thinking about it so looks
complicated the design actually is but
I'll run through it fairly simply people
are assigned to two kinds of conditions
this is the negative effect condition
person comes in there in the negative
effect condition now they go randomly
assigned either to an experience or role
or a partner role and the experience or
well they they watch a clip called my
bodyguard it's a it's a bullying clip
it's used in emotional contagion work to
put people into a negative effects
States a very upsetting clip people feel
very upset after watching that or they
watch what I'm gonna argue is one of the
most amazingly neutral like it's
fantastically neutral movies ever
there's like it's like boring doesn't
even describe it it's it's like
sublimely boring and then afterwards we
do a something called the penis' which
is an emotional test it tells us how
they're feeling from their positive
effect that's the PA and the negative
effect that's the na and then we told
them we were gonna get them to do
another separate experiment in which
they are gonna chat with each other it
was just via a G chat and their task was
to talk about tips for surviving
freshman year and our goal was could
these people at the end of talking to
this person feel crappier right feel
more negative effect the problem is what
we found we did a first study is that
actually afterwards everybody felt
really neutral and when we realized when
we looked at is there's this well-known
effect called the talking therapy which
is that just talking to another person
makes you feel better
so what we had to do was keep this
person in a really negative state so we
played really nasty dissonant
heavy-metal
on their headphones and they solved
anagrams - like angry and malice and
funeral and they were told it was a
multitasking experiment so they're
listening to music they're solving
anagrams and they're communicating okay
not unlike many of us do when we're
working these days okay the people down
here they're doing the same thing except
they're listening to kind of like
elevator jazz music and they're solving
you know those all right we do have
conditions where we make people really
happy just so you know I'm not like a
total mean person but this is pretty
mean and then afterwards we test them
for emotions again using a different
emotional test okay those are that's one
kind of a group called the negative
effect group and there's about 40 of
these in this experiment now there's
another group and all three people in a
team that was part of this condition
will be assigned to the negative they
are to the neutral neutral all the way
through yeah so everybody is
experiencing the neutral thing so we
have two conditions a neutral one
everybody's feeling neutral and we have
one in which there's one person in the
group that's experiencing really
negative effect already good now how do
we well we can confirm that after the
two movies they these people feel much
more negative effect which is what we're
interested in
then the sublimely boring one and we can
get to the question about now at the end
of all this how do they feel
here's the experience or experience that
has had a bad experience this negative
effect is very high the people in the
other condition okay so this is where
all the partners were experiencing
neutral effect this is how they feel
okay so this is the second condition I
showed you now the question is well
those two partners in the condition
where one of them is feeling negative
out so the two partners that are with
the experiencer F of negative effect is
taking place then these people should
look more like the experiencer that is
they should move away from this if
emotional contagion is not taking place
these people have experienced exactly
the same stimuli as these people
so if emotional contagion doesn't work
they're gonna look statistically
identical if it does work they're gonna
look statistically different towards the
experiencer wouldn't be telling you
about the study if it hadn't worked out
that way and here's what we see so it's
not a huge effect the partners that were
hanging out with this person they're
just typing with them they're chatting
with them feel worse than the people
over here that had to experience the
neutral effect think suggesting
emotional contagion okay now it is
important to know this is a very small
effect right this is you know we were
just probably at the threshold of being
able to detect this effect okay so after
this work a lot of people started
looking at emotions in networks and Adam
Kramer is one of them so you know his
interests were sort of dynamics through
this if indeed emotions can move through
text then what happens when you have a
large network in which people are
exchanging text how does emotion work
there so Adam Kramer had done a number
of studies on this and he was interested
in our work on emotional contagion so he
approached me with an experiment they
were going to be doing at Facebook in
which they were going to manipulate the
amount of emotional content in the posts
and he thought that it would have
emotional contagion relevance relevance
to the kind of work we were doing and
asked he wanted to be involved and I did
it sounded pretty fascinating so this is
the emotional contagion study that
Michael mentioned that came out in PNAS
very very very controversial two of
perhaps the most intense weeks of my
life and there's obviously a lot of
issues the study notes I think stands as
a an important artifact about the
ethical and methodological issues when
academics and industry work together
around these large data science type
projects and I'll talk a little bit
about that towards the end but I'm happy
to take questions and talk one-on-one
with all those who've had you know
hundreds and hundred conversations about
that aspect of the study but let me walk
you through the actual study the method
this is what the newsfeed looked like at
the time and this is my friend cliff
he's made a post and that is what we're
gonna focus on there these responses
here they were not part of the study
that Facebook did direct messages were
not part of it it was just post so these
are non directed posts on the newsfeed
that I'm sure all of you know well
there's four conditions here one in
which the algorithm withheld negative
post some percentage of negative posts
okay and so that means that in this
condition you would load it up and you
know Facebook has about 1,500 posts that
it could plausibly show you it's making
some decisions about what it thinks is
most relevant engaging for you and of
that load some percentage of negative of
posts with negative effect words would
not be represented in that loading okay
and so in that condition over here we
would expect compared to a condition in
which just random posts were withheld
okay so you have that 1,500 issue or so
random or without we would expect the
person would feel would then type in
their own posts less negative effect
because they're seeing less negative
effect what you probably are seen you're
thinking yeah but there's other reasons
why that could occur and you'd be
absolutely right mimicry right I just
see fewer negative emotions so I i mimic
that or you could think it's a normative
like oh it's not very negative today so
I'm gonna not gonna write very negative
so the key for emotional contagion is
that we then all motion contagions you'd
also be more positive okay you're gonna
post more positive posts all right let
me know if there's question that I can
walk through the logic one more time
over here over here there's negative
positive post remove help this is the
more controversial condition right so
positive posts from the feed now are
being withheld at some rate some
percentage and we would therefore then
predict less positive which could be
mimicry it could be normative but the
thing that I don't think can be
explained by something like mimicry but
can be by motion contagious that the
person would then be more
negative in their own posts yes that's a
good question and the manipulation here
was only based on the text so it was
using just the linguistic inquiry and
word count dictionary or some
approximation of that so if there was a
photo but it had a negative word and it
was in this condition there was a
likelihood it would be withheld good
question yes why is that a different
scale or metric then more positive
shouldn't those just be kind of ups
inside at the same point right and for a
long time
I think theorists thought it was but a
lot of work in psychology suggests that
they're actually independent so you can
you can be really happy and really sad
at the same time give me really happy
and not sad you can be really low on
happiness and low on sadness too that's
like a you know you're just chilling
you're not happy and you're not sad
right so it's actually not a continuum
and so most that's why the PAP a na s
which is the panas is the most popular
scale it measures positive affect and it
measures negative an effect separately
so I could share some papers of the
afterwards but most psychological
theories now assume those to be two
independent processes good question yes
the first question it was a seven day
period so the many patients having for
seven days and their posts are being
measured for seven days in terms of what
particular algorithm etc was used I am
not I don't know that information yes
posts are those normalized to the
emotional bands that the users previous
posting history no you're not and that
would be awesome to do that the way
we're relying on that is two ways the
first is this is a an experiment so we
would assume that just as many like
super perky people occur
in this condition as in this condition
unless random assignment failed but with
that in it's unlikely to fail and the
other is we're going to normalize it by
the percentage of total words that are
doing so I think that would help with
that but I would say we're relying on
the experimental methodology to deal
with that great questions okay so here
are the results I'll step through them
okay so this is the negativity withheld
condition in the light blue is the
experiment so there's fewer negative
posts in these people's feed and we see
indeed fewer negative posts produced by
those people we would expect that we
could expect that for a motion that a
gym but it could also be a mimicry like
some kind of automatic thing that has
nothing to do with emotion but
importantly for contagion we see that it
increases positivity okay so you see
much not much but you see significantly
higher statistically higher over there
okay and in the positive withheld one so
they're seeing fewer positive so we
should see fewer positive posts and
that's the light blue up there compared
to its control and importantly again for
contagion we see a change in negative
effect which again there's nothing
changing about negative effect in the
experiment but we see a change in
negative effect here which led us to
conclude that this is some evidence of
emotional contagion okay so a couple of
things with this one one things it
wasn't sort of like discussed or thought
about very much in the discussion of
this study was effect size in fact it's
not something that we as social
scientists have been very good talking
with the public about so what was the
effect of this well let's look at the
most controversial condition that's
where positive some percentage of
positive posts were being withheld the
effect sizes were such that a person in
this conditional on average would write
one fear positive emotion word okay so
one fewer positive word per 1000 that
they wrote and they would write form
or negative emotion words per 10,000 so
for a heavy user of Facebook they're
posting ten times a day
anybody here post ten times a day so
we're like you have to be pretty heavy
user it would take you about three years
to write 10,000 words in facebook posts
okay and you're producing four more
negative words on average so if you take
that to like three four five six
standard deviations out which would be
an extremely rare they're gonna produce
maybe sixteen to twenty four more
negative emotion words that's somebody
that was really affected by this okay
over three years so the effect size of
this is tiny in fact another criticism
of this study and studies of this nature
is that they're pointless because the
effect size is so minuscule fact you can
put all of the studies I've done for
sixteen years before this one together
all the participants and maybe I've had
about twenty thousand people through my
lab and we would not have detected these
differences they would have been null
according to the amount of people I've
had in my whole lifetime go through my
studies that's right so that aggregation
of these is really interesting and
really complicated we actually are
talked about that in the paper as like
these effects are really tiny and yet we
don't know how these kinds of effects
aggregate and that was it yet another I
mean there were many ways to critique
and that the ways that the study was
critiqued so good luck trying to
critique it in a new way because I've
heard it all is that's right is like
these effects are so small they're
pointless and the system is so big that
their ability to manipulate at Society
level is very worrisome right and both
of those are are important kind of
things to think about again I think of
this study now is as raising really
important questions as we do this this
kind of work more more and more
any other questions about this one one
of the things I'll just say quickly is
you know for a little while after about
two weeks of massive criticism about
this being unethical I did start to
doubt myself I can't deny that and I
sort of think did I just make a huge
error in in doing the study and doing it
in a way without informed consent and my
answer to that is actually partly to do
with what I've showed you before you
remember the emotional contagion
experiment I did we used a very heavy
manipulation to get them into two
different negative or positive effects
state with a with a movie that they
watched and then we had to continuously
make them feel bad by playing horrible
music continuously and having them solve
anagrams so we had these massive
manipulations in a lab where that was
the only thing they were doing and we
got very small effects so a pariah I
felt really comfortable these would be
small effects so a big question of this
is whether informed consent would have
been required and it's been a big point
of discussion there's a piece came out
of nature that was discussing this very
question it was signed by about 33
bioethicists these are people with PhDs
and ethics and the first night I had a
good night's sleep after this it was
about two weeks later when they
published that and said that they were
split on whether they thought this study
would require informed consent if it had
gone through IRB so that's you know
would I like it if they had all said no
it didn't require informants now that'd
be great
but at least what I meant was that I
wasn't in hadn't missed it in an
insanely you know it wasn't insanely bad
judgment on my part that it was a
debatable thing and you may feel very
strongly one way or the other and I'd
totally respect that okay yeah
James understanding what's going on
Facebook why is why is there not work
here why are these fun experiments go
yeah right think about that yeah it's a
great questions it is one of theirs come
up with many times so why this study and
not like say others and it's certainly a
multi factored
thing all the things that you mentioned
James like when I was writing this I
wasn't thinking about like how means if
people would read about it in the news
so yeah using you know like experiment
emotional contagion massive you know
like a like manipulation all the words
that in science we value as indicating
good rigorous work
sounds like guinea pig to the other
people would be one the other is I think
people have shields over time about
being manipulated and one example is
advertising so there was a really nice
case of advertising in the forties a
book and it went over how there was a
period when people realized that
advertisers were experimenting to see
which ones are most effective and then
they could do this without your
awareness and there was such a thing as
subliminal advertising advertising as we
know it almost ceased to be possible but
what ended up happening instead was that
we decided it was okay so if I say to
people like hey do you know like when
you walk into a grocery store you're
being experimented on or when you read
magazines it's there's an experimental
design most be like yeah that's
advertising in this case I don't think
there was any shield they had no idea
many people had no idea in fact one of
things I did was analyzed and was
talking with HCI seminar group about
this is like a good social scientist I
had a lot of data which was I there was
this disturbance in the world and I was
able to see some of the reasons why
people are being disturbed because they
wrote me a lot of hate mail so what I
did is I have analyzed all my email did
I receive that was about the Facebook
study and one of the one of the main
themes is this sort of my newsfeed is
manipulated so again and again I saw
emails that were like how dare you mess
with my stuff right like this this idea
that it that that that it's a that's
it's a manipulated thing and that it's
not like my social life objectively
viewed was really
upsetting to James's point the other is
something that in our research and in
the social media service space we knew
but certainly is not the meme and that
is that the newsfeed is actually really
important to people it is not like just
a trivial thing here's an example my
friend's dad just passed away and if I
was in this experiment I'd never have
known people this is a major resource
now for people's social lives emotions
are distinct that you know you can't
just like play with my emotions their
mind that was very strong so this idea
of mood control and mind control was
frequently mentioned and that um I want
to say ironically but maybe it's not
ironic it's more of a paradox but that
big data's really personal so when I was
doing experiments up on a hill in Ithaca
with students and people would read
about my work I'd study deception and
technology so it would get in the media
they didn't care because it was
happening of some people in a lab on a
hill but when it's that scale it's big
data it could be me and so that was a
big thing is I want to know if I was in
your study
probably because then I'm gonna sue you
but it was really about like was I in
your study was I in your study he was on
your study very I've never had anything
like that before
so it got us thinking and me in
particular about this idea of people not
not having an idea that the news feed is
algorithmic can manipulated regularly
and tested in order to see if it works
for people and so we've got a big
project going I talked about this with
the HSR group already a little bit but
we want to understand what what are the
folk theories people have about it
Michael was mentioning at the beginning
of the talk so I won't go into the
details of how we do this study but
we're basically trying to surface folk
theories about how people think about
the news feed which is this like
massively complicated and dynamic system
right like the news feed is receiving
billions of inputs at whatever time
scale you want to say
so how do people represent this insanely
complicated thing so here are the
foremost metaphors that we have so far
and we're about to do a none of the run
event we'll see how these hold over time
but paparazzi got me to show what's hot
and popular personal shopper choose an
offering just the content I want
magazine a collection of various stories
that might interest you and spy and so
you can start to seek some quick themes
here there's like negative connotations
paparazzi and spy and personal shopper
magazine or positive and so we think
like depending on what your metaphor
your folk theory of what this thing is
it's gonna affect the way you engage
with it and this has really important
HSI implications and they're starting to
be some work done here I list some of my
you know studies there's very few but
these are the the ones that I really
like so far so that this is an exciting
area if any students are interested in
this I'm be happy to talk more all right
so let's go through the last one I told
you about one of my favorite studies I'm
gonna go over fairly briefly but basic
idea here is that text can't provide the
psyche of social aspect so that's a
psychological and the social aspect that
a face-to-face can yeah that's very
possible but one thing that also is
possible is that text itself can be
something of its own not everything has
to be compared to face-to-face is like
some gold standard I'm sure all of you
have thought you know what I should just
text him rather than go to his office
and meet the person and say hey do you
want to meet at lunch at noon it'd be
easier actually to do that by text well
there are ways in which text can be
supportive so here's the here's the set
up well I'll show you that this study
first I'll tell you how it came about it
we've been doing all this work looking
at how if somebody's looking at a steep
hill and they have a heavy backpack on
if they have a friend nearby they
actually judge the hill is less steep so
that's the nice psychological work and
we've done some work to say well if
they're judge if they're looking at the
hill and right before they do that they
text somebody that they care about they
know would that affect and sure enough
when you text somebody the hill looks
less steep
so we're talking about this and then my
brother-in-law happened to be visiting
he's north he's a a what's the guy oh my
god I'm forgetting what is what's that
anesthesiologist Scott thank you okay I
got to tell him that you're so
unimportant that I forgot what you do
he's anesthesiologist he comes to one of
our lab meetings he hears about these
studies that were doing he's like hey
Jeff do you think we could do this
during surgery and I was like no because
you literally have put them to sleep
that's your job he's like oh no no no no
there's many many studies because
there's this big move or many many
surgeries in which we only NSI them from
the waist down and the reason for that
is there's a huge move in anesthesiology
to reduce the amount of narcotics to the
bare minimum required to do it because
otherwise there's complications it takes
longer to recover and so he's like yeah
we could do this where they're an SI
from the waist down and they can they
can text I was like huh that's a great
idea so we had to texting conditions so
that people come in they're randomly
assigned and they are getting operated
on their knees hips groin whole region
I'll just leave it at that
and they're either texting a loved one
that had come into the room or into the
surgery like brought into the surgery
they're not in the surgery room they're
in the waiting room or they text a
stranger this is somebody we were paying
to interact with these people they just
had like nice get to meet you
conversations with them and they texted
during the surgery what we needed to do
then was have some good controls so we
had a distraction control so they were
playing Angry Birds while they're
getting operated on and then we had a
standard operating procedures so they
had no phone it was like as if there was
a normal operation and then what we do
here is they do that one of these
conditions they get measured for our
amount of anxiety people typically break
anxious then they get their spinal tap
so now they can't actually feel anything
from the waist down but once we will
need narcotics to get through it it's
very anxiety-provoking people perceive
breakthrough pain and things like that
so what we're gonna do is use fentanyl
intake fentanyl's are very powerful
narcotics 100 times more powerful than
morphine
I've been told my brother-in-law will
not let me try it
so our DV is how much fentanyl do they
need to get through the surgery okay and
at the end in case there's any
differences between these two texting a
friend Texas stranger we analyzed
linguistically the messages between the
the person and their either their their
loved one their friend or a stranger
here's the data this is the control
condition this is micrograms of fentanyl
so how much fentanyl did they require in
order to get through the surgery and we
can see that they need on average y'all
it's about 33 micrograms the distraction
task is here that is better but not
statistically better than control both
of these both of the texting conditions
are better than nothing but only one the
texting a stranger is better than the
distraction task all right we had okay
I'll just tell you the truth I was
betting on texting a loved one a
companion because I thought it was gonna
be much really about like that
psychosocial support having a loved one
holding your hand can reduce anxiety for
example so it was texting a stranger now
I was wrong
others on the team were right you guys
have any thoughts - why the Texas
stranger was the better intervention to
kind of pull yourself together you have
to be you play more roll with it explore
concentration yeah maybe good I I agree
with everything up into the
concentration thing but you and you
might be right I think it's more you get
transported out a little bit more right
you're talking this other person yeah we
it was in Montreal so we needed somebody
that spoke both French and English and
she had done some work at the hospital
so she we just recruit her and asked her
to do that just been that your stranger
just happened to be like experience that
this is comforting people yes absolutely
and so we need to create your systems or
people that in you oh she did she did do
say that's true she I can show you
something that she does that's different
than the other people yes so it is
exactly essentially it was like this
awful anxiety feedback loop there like I
think your knee now are you all right oh
my god I'm freaking out you're freaking
out I'm freaking out oh my god so you
can see here in green is our stranger
who may be an extra compassionate person
and but we don't know and texted
companion and you can see more negative
emotion with the companion and less
positive okay and in fact you see what
they talk about is they're talking about
biology all the time oh my god they're
in your knee oh my god they're in your
knee and oh my god are you dying you
know those kind of things right whereas
with a stranger what did it sound like
well actually you look at them and
they're very self affirming it turns out
just to bring it back to the beginning
there are a lot of conversations but yes
so what do you do do you have family do
you have kids right there's all the
things I talk about the beginning of the
class
there's self-affirming there's things
that are important when you know someone
a loved one you already know all that
stuff and you're not going to talk about
it so my guess is that the loved one has
some advantages and some disadvantages
and the stranger has some advantages and
maybe not as many disadvantages but
that's the idea the overall point though
is that this was just text right it
wasn't you seen my face it wasn't me
holding your hand and it had a
significant effect on how much of a drug
you had to get in order to make through
a surgery and you know a significant
amount these effect sizes are much
larger than the ones I was showing you
for the emotional contagion work okay
and that point here is that as I said at
the beginning is just because we're
using technology to do something
socially doesn't mean that all of the
work we've done over the last 50 years
or so in social science needs to go out
the window and that ultimately is my
conclusion and I'd love to hear any
questions from you guys thank you very
much for your attention
yes you know in fact this morning I just
had a text I've stuck with somebody and
said to them this is not a good way for
us to be communicated perfect for today
but you know you're talking about grand
emotions good emotions bad emotions it's
the subtleties I think that you know
yeah what about the subtleties of you
I'm here you're frustrated if it's a
negative emotion which one is it because
I think there's a lot of differences
between good negative emotion so if
you're getting the wrong negative
emotion it's pretty it's absurd right
we're kind of at the kindergarten level
I think right now if studies of emotion
it's really hard
motions are really hard to study I was
talking to with one of the students at a
meeting today and we were talking about
this idea of like you know people
represent their emotions Acura on
Facebook or is it more performed and in
real life and it's just hard because you
expect during this talk today I've
experienced many emotions right and it's
only 45 minutes so I experienced anxiety
when I talk about the Facebook study
again I experienced joy when I hear you
guys laugh and it's really quick and
it's dynamic and they flow together and
there's multiple so it's yeah it's very
difficult I think is and it's not a
great answer for you but what I think is
that all those beautiful and lovely and
sophisticated dynamics of emotion don't
disappear when we use technology they
get transformed in some ways they're
they're pushed around in some ways that
I think are systemic but it's not that
we're all just immediately become like a
emotional and narcissistic you know
people yes so what's your view on emojis
a sort of an extended alphabet to
express emotions yeah well I don't have
a scientific opinion of them yet but I
have a number of students over in comm
that have come up and want to do Studies
on emojis but I'll tell you they're fun
and I laugh and I I have really really
enjoyable conversations I mean they just
strike me as really creative and
interesting forms of conversation I
don't think that the emo part of emojis
is really accurate for us and it comes
from emoticons I think that was a really
unfortunate
term because I don't think emoticons
really have anything to do with emotion
I think they're about signaling how
you're taking a message or how you want
somebody else to take a message
emojis might be different because they
really they're much more you know
they're much more expressive so I'd i I
don't think they represent emotion
emoticons and emojis I think are
fascinating fun and delightful but I
haven't done a lot of scientific work on
it good question so going back to the
old to CMC literature like as introduced
cues you get things like more flaming
and so on I'm wondering it you were to
rewrite that now what would be in the
textbook that you would write yeah we'd
still have a lot of flaming writing on
line so right you know it seems like
you're trying to modulate that someone I
don't know what you would say to great
question and this you know with excuse
me comments so we all know that comments
tend to be really negative and a little
bit unhinged but I got interesting them
as one other thing when all the comments
would be written about any you know any
work that you do or you see a scientific
article and then you look at the
comments and it's like really this is
the response and so I do think it's a my
mom watches you know shows like these uh
daily TV shows made for TV show she
really likes her stories you know and
other people watch soap operas and stuff
I suspect and I don't have a good
estimation this yet that comments are
kind of like soap operas they're a way
to feel emotion so you can go into those
comments and get really upset or really
excited and and they're a way to
experience that in a in a sort of like
novel anonymous way and you see it
everything I all look at a hockey game
review and you just look at the comments
and they're just hatred in there there's
love of their team very emotionally rich
things how fat the pipe is how much
emotional signals coming through and
much more about it being a space and yes
we expect to create and receive motion
yeah and so I you know if some students
in here we're emailing me or my stood
Dave's here like I wouldn't expect him
to like all of a sudden produce the
flame in my email right because there's
norms in place and we have a
relationship but in this other place
this context there's this anonymous
space maybe norms have already been set
in which you can be really extreme so
it's much more you're right about
context and social expectations than
about the pipeline yes ways to
communicate emotionally on social media
that aren't face to face but they also
aren't only text like means or like oh I
love this song right now yeah this is
how I'm feeling yeah this i watch this
episode and you're sharing with someone
else something that communicates that
your emotion do you plan to study those
at all yeah so it turns out like photos
are increasingly important as an example
but all media yeah exactly an Instagram
is astonishing as an expressive medium
and I'll just be honest it's taken me a
while to adjust so I did all my training
in the 90s and like all of the internet
was text at that point and doing
multimedia to work is really hard so
we're doing a lot of work right now on
deception so Dave and I are teaching a
class and a number of the groups are
working on like what is deception in a
photo on Instagram and is a filter and
are the captions and see yeah it's a
really it's becoming a really rich space
to do emotion work yeah video oh and
it's just your speculation of what you
think people's mental model of their
emotions is because you talked about it
variously in ads it's like well yeah
it's not so their emotion manipulating
me we're in face we were like no I feel
like you called them distinct or
whatever they're like mediate like and I
think people who's wronged through the
grief and realize their stages feel more
like okay my emotions are certain like a
process running inside me but they
aren't me and maybe people have
different notions of those but what are
what different models make you is it's a
really good idea and I don't know the
answer I would guess there's some
evidence that people that take for
instance different types of therapies so
let's say you do CBT versus something
else that you develop different
theories of how your emotions work it's
a great it's a great question and I
don't I don't know the answer but
presumably those sort of thinking about
the way you are then interact with the
way you think this abstract algorithm is
and so yeah there's a whole space here
that I think is just completely
unexplored yeah Dave you shouldn't ask
any questions you're my student this is
my facebook profile versus this isn't my
ad right so my profile is something very
different this I've curated I've done
all these things to my profile versus
this ad was done by someone else and
it's given to me because of two phases
that people do feel ownership over the
content in their newsfeed in ways that
they wouldn't about like eye magazines
advertising or something yeah yeah
that's a good point
yeah yeah there's another potential
complication to your facebook reaction
which is at least on the right if you're
interested in privacy Facebook has a
reputation for unfriendly users yeah
yeah this is a big concern for them
right like they're they're very worried
about their reputation of trust or not
and this is me speaking as Jeff Hancock
I don't represent Facebook at all but I
think you're absolutely right yeah I
think that this was really an issue for
them because they reduced trust in them
and what they do and raised all these
privacy questions so I you know I have a
lot of students and friends that have
gone into to work at Facebook and other
companies a lot of companies any
consumer facing company has some sort of
social media aspect and yeah I see these
as people that care about these
questions and I think you know they're
working on it so Facebook for instance
has a a really big group working on
bullying and I think that the reason I'm
excited to see people from active
especially with PhDs going into
companies with data Sciences because
they bring our values there and I see it
as a long hopeful and I'm an optimist
transformation of of the values that
take place they're aligning more towards
thinking about people's autonomy and
privacy and does that get at your
question or something I mean I'm yeah
it's an optimistic view yeah all these
really interesting findings about motion
contagion and others when part of it is
as a social scientist you have been sort
of looking at existing systems existing
media and how that affects people's
emotions resident and for system
designers I think one of the questions
that he is you know based on this
finding what can we learn to design
better platforms right thoughts to share
yeah you know this is the only thing if
we if this study had been done and I
wasn't involved and we didn't write up a
thing about emotional contagion but
instead Facebook did a report saying
yeah it turns out that if we make people
you know if the news feeds more positive
people are more positive it would not be
a big controversy right so right I think
this is important and and there's some
responsibilities that designers have if
what I'm saying in general is right
which is that the things that we use
have genuine psychological impact on us
then it behooves us to test the things
I've been arguing in talking about the
study that we need to embrace
evidence-based design right and so if
the evidence suggests that actually
things like the news feed can have an
effect on your emotion and the way you
view your friendships then shouldn't we
be studying that to make sure that it's
it's it's supporting your goals and what
you want to have happened and it gets
complicated because in academia that'd
be pretty straightforward when there's a
company involved and again this is part
of that thing they have certain values
too and again speaking from my own and
not as a facebook person but these
companies have actually priorities that
may not be aligned with the user they
they are behold like they have
shareholders and they're actually
legally bound to their shareholders so
lots of complications but we can't shy
away from this this is so for me I see
this is like Tecna watch talks about
like the telescope changes you know
astronomy to me social media data in
these companies is change is going to
change social science in the same
transformative way and if we shy away
from this and just say well you know
this is too complicated and regulatory
regimes are too different I then that
would be a really negative outcome in my
view and people always ask me - you got
anything about the study and I do I
would very much regret that it would
decrease trust in science that takes
place in this new in this new space and
so I you know I think that there's been
a lot of progress since the controversy
to get people are able to publish in
ways that they feel protected that they
feel the participants are protected so
yeah I'm optimistic I think that it was
a it happened and I hope that some good
can come out of the negative that it
caused if company decided that they
wanted one party in versus another
they actually have you know information
how to do that know there was this
substantial change in voting behavior
that they're like hundreds of thousands
of more votes for one condition than the
other yeah yeah
I appreciate it
you